ich weiß dass ich manchmal zu
leidenschaftlich wirke ich weiß dass
viele von euch das nicht mögen aber bei
dieser Wahl geht es nicht um mich
sondern um
euch bei dieser Wahl geht es darum ob
wir den Kurs fortsetzen wollen der uns
seit Jahrzehnten zum Scheitern gebracht
hat oder ob wir etwas anders machen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wollenardo hat die Wahl zum Präsidenten
Argentiniens gewonnen er hat sich mit
fast 56% der Stimmen gegen seinen
linksperronistischen Widersacher und
amtierenden Finanzminister Sergio Massa
durchgesetzt der libertäre mi der von
einigen als der Donald Trump
Argentiniens bezeichnet wird ist zu
einem politischen Phänomen geworden und
das nicht nur in Argentinien sein Sieg
ist womohöglich Teil einer neuen großen
internationalen Welle des Libertarismus
welche die Weltpolitik maßgeblich
verändern
könnte die ganze Welt hat zugesehen ich
bin sehr stolz auf euch ihr werdet die
Wände in eurem Land schaffen und
Argentinien wieder groß machen
Argentinien steht Wohlstand bevor Elon
Musk die extreme Rechte hat in
Argentinien gewonnen das ist traurig für
Amerika cololumbiens linksgichteter
Präsident Gustavo Petro aber einige von
euch werden sich jetzt sicher fragen
wieso dies auch gerade für uns in Europa
hochgradig relevant sein sollte wieso
könnte ausgerechet m wahsieg im fern
Argentinien einen but Einfluss auf das
Schicksal und den Wohlstand Europas
haben nun überlegt mal der russische
Krieg in der Ukraine zwang die EU sich
dringend von russischem Öl und Gas
unabhängig zu machen kurzfristig halft
teures LNG Gas doch eine nachhaltige
Lösung fehlt noch vor allem weil große
Mengen dieses Gases noch immer von
Diktatoren eingekauft werden die unserer
Lebensweise nicht gerade wohl gesonnen
sind aber siehe da mit der Erschließung
Lateinamerikas als Rohstofflieferant
könnte sich dies entscheidend ändern
Südamerika verfügt fügt nämlich über
gewaltige Reserven aber seine
innenpolitischen Probleme und
infrastrukturdefizite verhindern bisher
dass es Russland ersetzen kann tja und
melei steht für eine starke Annährung
seines Landes und ganz Lateinamerikas an
Europa die USA und den freien Welthandel
und die gleichzeitige Abkehr von China
und totalitären Regimes er will sein
Land wieder auf Fordermann bringen
öffnen und eine winwinituation schaffen
und wird er damit in Argentinien Erfolg
haben könnte diese Welle viele andere
Länder der zwei Welt sowohl in
Südamerika als auch anderswo mitreisen
auch Europa könnte ein großer Gewinner
sein dass sich ihm viele neue stabile
und demokratische Märkte öffnen würden
eine goldene era könnte uns bevorstehen
noch allerdings liegt ein langer und
beschwerlicher Weg vor uns wenn auch der
erste Schritt am Sonntag beschritten
worden ist fest steht sein Sieg hat M
bereits als Shootingstar auf die
internationale Bühne gebracht und jetzt
gibt es viele die sich seinen Aufstieg
auf die ein oder andere Weise zu nutzen
machen wollen Lopez ador beschwor die
Geister von Hitler und des
Nationalsozialismus als er den Triumph
von mele erklärte bolsonaro feierte den
Sieg von mi das könnte der wahre Wandel
sein den Argentinien braucht während mi
noch vor einem Jahr ein politischer
nobody und das Phänomen seine
Unterstützung vielleicht nur ein
Ausdruck des überdrusses von ein paar
protestwählerern war ist er nun zu einer
unaufhaltsamen Kraft geworden die Wall
Street Bank die mit einem Sieg von mi
bei den Präsidentschaftswahlen rechnet
laut Wells Fargo hat der libertäre
Kandidat hat eine 65przentige Chance
dieses Jahr zum Präsidenten gewählt zu
werden k mele rechnete damit dass er vom
IWF kontaktiert wird und dass sie sich
in den nächsten Tagen treffen werden der
Tsunami der Wut und die Enttäuschung
viele Argentinier hat den Außenseiter m
ganz nach oben gespült die
Inflationsrate liegt bei
138%. rund 40% der Menschen in dem einst
reichen Land leben unter der
Armutsgrenze wir haben über die goldenen
Zeiten und dann den beispiellosen
Absturz des einst prosperierenden Landes
sogar ein eigenes Video gedreht dass ich
euch verlinken werde heute leidet
Argentinien unter einem aufgebläten
Staatsapparat geringer
industrieproduktivität und einer großen
Schattenwirtschaft die dem Staat viele
Steuereinnahmen entzieht die
Landeswährung Peso verliert gegenüber
dem Dollar immer weiter an Wert das
schuldenwerk wächst und wächst aber wie
kam es nun zu einer solchen libertären
Welle im Land der gautchos wieso haben
sie ihr Heil nicht wie in der
Vergangenheit im linken perronismus
gesucht woher kommt ihr libertärer
Sinneswandel und was genau sind die
Positionen mis was ist sein Masterplan
für argenent heute werden wir hier auf
visualpolitik all diese Fragen restlos
beantworten und zwar gleich nach der
kurzen Botschaft unseres Trollen
Sponsors AG1 denn schließlich hat er das
heutige Video nicht nur mit seinem
finanziellen Beitrag möglich gemacht
nein er hilft uns auch weit darüber
hinaus was ich damit meine nun sicher
könnt ihr euch vorstellen dass dieser
Job hier nicht durchzuhalten ist wenn
man sich nicht ordentlich in Form hält
gerade in diesen dunklen Wintertagen
wenn die Sonne schon früh untergeht und
viele von uns mit Müdigkeit kämpfen ist
es entscheidend Wege zu finden um
Energie geladen zu bleiben AG wonders
aus zehntelanger Forschung entstanden
und bereits 52 mal weiterentwickelt und
optimiert wurde hilft mir während des
ganzen Arbeitstages im Flow zu bleiben
und meinen mentalen Fokus auf das zu
konzentrieren was zählt um mein
Energiestoffwechsel in Schwung zu halten
unterstützten mich folgende Bestandteile
meiner allmorgendlichen Portion AG1
Kupfer Biotin pantetonsäure tiamin und
die Vitamine B2 B12 und C das ist nicht
einfach so daher gesagt sondern eine
evidenzbasierte Tatsache und wenn ihr
mir nicht glaubt dann schaut euch doch
z.B an womit sich Joe Rogan fit hält
ebenfalls AG bon auch in den Kommentaren
unter unseren Videos schreiben uns immer
wieder viele Zuschauer die W ausprobiert
haben und sehr zufrieden damit sind okay
klar ist ein Nahrungsergänzungsmittel
ersetzt keine ausgewogene Ernährung
deswegen heißt es ja nur
Ergänzungsmittel aber es hilft mir eben
dabei mit einer gesünderen Routine
unbelastet in den Tag zu starten vor
allem ist
nicht nur für meinen individuellen
Anwendungsbereich geeignet sondern
bietet noch viele weitere
gesundheitliche Vorteile über die ihr
mehr erfahren könnt wenn ihr auf den
Link in der Beschreibung klickt dort
erfahrt ihr auch weitere Details darüber
welche Inhaltsstoffe genau welch Nutzen
bringen und wie Sie ob optimal
aufeinander abgestimmt sind um
Synergieeffekte und eine hohe
Bioverfügbarkeit zu erzielen fakt ist H1
ist ketofreundlich und die wertvollen
Mikronährstoffe werden aus echten
natürlichen veganen Nahrungsmitteln wie
Erbsen oder Soja gewonnen ohne
künstliche Zusatzstoffe außerdem
schmeckt es auch noch gut mir
zumindest aber natürlich darf man es wie
alles nicht überdosieren sollte auf
Allergene achten und vor allem nicht
einnehmen wenn man schwanger ist oder
stillt ich empfehle euch auf jeden Fall
mal eine Ernährungsberatung zu machen um
festzustellen was genau ihr braucht um
euch besser zu fühlen und gesünder zu
leben mir persönlich hilft die oben
genannte Kombination mit H1 am besten
denn es deckt meiner Ansicht nach die
meisten Fälle zufriedenstellend ab und
passend dazu bietet H1 unserer Community
sogar ein besonderes Angebot wenn du auf
den Link in der Videobeschreibung
klickst erhältst du bei Abschluss eines
monatlichen Abos einen kostenlosen
Jahresvorrat an Vitamin D3 und K2 und
fünf praktische AG1 travel Packs für
unterwegs gratis dazu neukunden erhalten
außerdems 1 welcome Kit inklusive shier
Aufbewahrungsdose und einen praktischen
Shaker das ganze ist ein Abo aber ohne
laufzeitbindung du kannst es jederzeit
nachbelieben anpassen pausieren oder
einfach kündigen also worauf wartest du
noch probier on doch einfach mal ganz
unverbindlich aus und unterstütze auch
deine Ernährung auf einfache und gesunde
Weise übrigens falls ihr auch unsere
Arbeit direkt unterstützen möchtet könnt
ihr dies über den Spendenlink in der
Beschreibung tun auf dass wir euch noch
viele weitere interessante Videos wie
dieses liefern können und wenn ihr das
erledigt habt lasst uns herausfinden was
hinter dem melei Tsunami steckt
[Applaus]
[Musik]
aufgepasst
trotz des großen Auf und Ab in
wirtschaftlichen Fragen hat die
argentinische Politik in gewisser Weise
ein mehr oder weniger konstanten Faden
in der ersten Hälfte des 20 Jahrhunderts
mit der Konsolidierung der Demokratie
entstand die radikale BürgerUnion das
war die erste große Massenpartei die
sogar die ersten drei offenen Wahlen
gewannen die von 1916 1922 und 1900 28
aber mit dem Staatsstreich von 1930
mischten die Streitkräfte dann voll im
politischen Leben mit von da an war die
argentinische Demokratie sagen wir mal
eher unregelmäßig ein Staatsstreich
folgt dem anderen und jahrelang war die
Demokratie auf bestimmte Zeiträume
beschränkt in einem dieser Zeiträume
tauchte Juan Domingo Peron auf der die
peronistische Bewegung gründete und
erlegte damit den Grundstein für die
argentinische Demokratie die fortan
Bestand haben sollte auf der einen Seite
steht der antiperonismus der in der
Regel mit der Union civica radikal der
radikalen BürgerUnion und ihren Partnern
verbunden ist und auf der anderen Seite
der perronismus der von der Partie der
justizialista der gerechtigkeitspartei
unterstützt wird da haben wir es also
das ist das Tandem dass die
argentinische Politik seit der Rückkehr
der Demokratie im Jahr 1983 vollständig
dominiert in den letzten 10 Jahren wurde
dieses du unter verschiedenen Namen von
den oppositionskoalition gemeinsam für
den Wandel und der regierenden
perronistischen Koalition Union für das
Vaterland vertreten und so lief es die
ganze Zeit bis eine dritte Kraft eine
Lücke erkannte und plötzlich in die
Politik eines Landes mit einer
zerstörten wirtschaftinstieg die Rede
ist natürlich von La libertat avanza die
Freiheit schreitet voran la libertat
avanza ist die politische Partei jaier
mes bereits bei den Vorwahlen 2023 haben
die libertären nicht nur einen
beispiellosen nationalen Sieg errungen
sondern auch eine enorme Anzahl von
Stimmen im landesinn in Provinzen und
Gemeinden die eigentlich Hochburgen der
peronisten sind damals haben sowohl in
der Bundeshauptstadt als auch in der
provinzbostires gemeinsam für den Wandel
und Union für das Vaterland ihre Stimmen
halten können das bedeutet dass kavier
mi seinen nationalen Triumph Anfang des
Jahres dank seiner Sieger in Orden
errungen hat an denen kein Gegner des
Peronismus eine solche Leistung
vollbracht hat zumindest nicht in den
letzten fünf Jahrzehnten nun in der
zweiten Runde hat M komfortable
Mehrheiten sowohl in der
Landeshauptstadt als auch in allen
Provinzen eingefahren aber was genau war
die Chance die ih nutzte wie um alles in
der Welt hat er es geschafft einen
solchen Sog auszulösen ein Mann der erst
2019 in die Politik ging das sind die
ersten beiden Fragen die wir beantworten
müssen bevor wir uns genau ansehen was
Mili mit Argentinien eigentlich vorhat
also lasst uns
[Musik]
loslegen wieat
Enttäuschung über
makrib wisst ihr was der coralito ist
nun der coralito war ein eine
wirtschaftspolitische Maßnahme die Ende
2001 in Argentinien eingeführt wurde
dieser Begriff bedeutet wirklich kleiner
Pferch und wird metaphorisch verwendet
um eine Situation zu beschreiben in der
die Bewegungsfreiheit stark
eingeschränkt ist im Kontext der
argentinischen Wirtschaftskrise wurde
der coralito eingeführt um einen
massiven Kapitalabfluss zu verhindern
die Regierung unter Präsident Fernando
de laarua verhängte strenge Kontrollen
über bankabhebungen und den Umtausch von
pesus in ausländische Währungen die
Argentinier konnten somit nur sehr
begrenzt auf ihre eigenen Bankguthaben
zugreifen die maßn en führten zu großem
öffentlichen Unmut und waren einer der
Hauptgründe für die politische und
wirtschaftliche Instabilität in
Argentinien zu dieser Zeit diese
Kapitalverkehrskontrollen hatten
tiefgreifende Auswirkungen auf die
argentinische Gesellschaft und
Wirtschaft viele Menschen verloren ihr
Vertrauen in das Banksystem und es kam
zu zahlreichen Protesten und Unruhen die
Krise führte letztlich zum Rücktritt von
Präsident delarua und hatte langfristige
Auswirkungen auf die argentinische
Wirtschaft und das internationale
Finanzsystem und nun haben der coralito
und der Crash von 2001 einem Landplatz
gemacht in dem der Wechselkurs die
neuesten Inflationszahlen und die Löhne
und Gehälter im Mittelpunkt der
übermäßigen gesellschaftlichen
Aufmerksamkeit stehen und vielleicht ist
das der Grund warum auch wenn es euch im
Land der ewigen Krise seltsam vorkommen
mag Wirtschaftswissenschaften der
beliebteste Studiengang an
argentinischen Universitäten sind jedes
Jahr schließen in Argentinien fast 15
000 Ökonomen und bwlerer ihr Studium ab
die anhaltende Dauerkrise hat eben
wirtschaftliche Fragen in Argentinien zu
einem großen und wachsenden politischen
und gesellschaftlichen Anliegen gemacht
die Wirtschaft ist also der wahre
Rockstar der der politischen Debatte in
Argentinien ist das Thema Inflation beim
Weihnachtsessen ein sehr beliebtes Thema
und wisst ihr was dank dieses
medienwibel fand eines schönen Tages ein
Wirtschaftswissenschaftler der sich
allmählich von der Masse abheben würde
Platz in den Medien die Rede ist
natürlich von folgendes Video Stand vom
25 August 2015 schaut euch
an
nach und nach und dank der Kampagne 2015
begann den neue libertäre Ikone mehr und
mehr in den Medien präsent zu sein zu
dieser Zeit hatten m Intervention ein
eher technisches Profil vor allem seine
Kritik an den preisintervention der
Regierung von Christina Fernandes der
Kirchner Star
[Musik]
hervor und tatsache ist dass der
Peronismus bei den anschließenden Wahlen
verloren hat
wurde am 10 Dezember deselben Jahres zum
neuen Präsidenten Argentiniens gewählt
die Hoffnungen auf einen großen Wandel
waren mehr als greifbar die Erwartungen
lagen sehr hoch wahrscheinlich zu
[Applaus]
hoch
Regierung hatte mit vielen Problemen zu
kämpfen 2016 ging es in der großen
Debatte darum ob die neue Regierung eine
schockpolitik betreiben oder auf ein
schrittweises Programm setzen sollte das
nach und nach Veränderungen einführt am
Ende setzte sich die zweite Möglichkeit
durch der Versuch während der Reformen
eine gewisse Stabilität und ein
höhresmaß an Konsens und sozialen
Frieden anzustreben führte dazu dass die
Regierung so schrittweise vorging dass
die meisten Veränderungen am Ende kaum
noch wahrnehmbar waren deshalb konnte
makrismo schon bald nicht mehr alle
Erwartungen erfüllen die in diese neue
era gesetzt wurden am Ende wurden wieder
die öffentlichen Ausgaben stark gekürzt
noch wurde das Defizit beseitigt noch
wurde eine große Liberalisierung der
Wirtschaft beschlossen alles blieben
mehr oder weniger beim alten 29 juli
2016 fiskalisches Defizit das Ziel wird
erreicht verzögert aber weiterhin das
Wachstum die Regierung hält an ihrer
schuldenfinanzierten Strategie der
schrittweisen Senkung des Haushalts im
Bereich fest bestimmt aber auch die
Erholung der Aktivität im Jahr 2017
damals positionierte sich M als Vorbild
für diejenigen die mit dem ersten Weg
einverstanden waren schnelle und Tiefe
einschritte damals wurde die heißeste
Version dieses Kandidaten geboren die
Formel die in zum dritten Weg in der
argentinischen Politik machen sollte 29
mai 2017 m warnte das schrittweise
anpassungspläne in der Krise
en
[Musik]
am Ende war die regierungri ein Desaster
die Inflation schoss in die Höhe und die
wirtschaftliche Lage war so schlecht
dass er den IWF erneut um ein
Rettungspaket bitten musste kein Wunder
das bei den folgenden Wahlen der
Peronismus zurückkehrte und zwar durch
die Vordertür sie brauchten dafür nicht
einmal die zweite
[Musik]
Wahlrunde bei den Wahlen 2019 gab es
eine marktwirtschaftlich
jis er erhielt zwar nur 1,47% der
Stimmen aber ironischerweise schuf er
damit einen neuen Weg der offen bleiben
würde bei den folgenden Parlamentswahl
führtenpert und eine gemeinsame
Alternative an die fast 1,3 Millionen
Stimmen
erhielt das war das
groetische
der Stimmen Abgeordneter für die
Bundeshauptstadt wurde insgesamt gewann
die libertäre Plattform auf nationaler
Ebene vier Abgeordnete das war also der
Anfang von da an nahm mis
Bekanntheitsgrad exponentiell zu als die
peronisten wieder an der Regierung waren
fand seine harte Botschaft immer mehr
Anklang mil wurde plötzlich zu einer der
wichtigsten Figuren der Opposition und
natürlich begann der Peronismus mit
einer derart katastrophalen Politik und
inmitten der Pandemie sich aufzulösen
zeitweise schien einfach alles eine
echte Katastrophe zu sein 20 Februar
2021 Argentiniens impfstoffskandal
Gesundheitsminister tritt nach
Enthüllungen über irreguläre Impfungen
von amtstträgern und anderen VIPs zurück
28 Juni 2021 argentinien ist laut
Bloomberg Ranking das Schlimmste Land in
dem man die Pandemie verbringen
kann 17 Juni 2021 das argentinische
Bildungssystem auf dem Tiefpunkt Ende
letzten Jahres warnte der flascoorscher
Augustin Klaus vor einer Hochrechnung
die besagt dass fast 1,5 Millionen Kind
der nach der Quarantäne die Schule
abgebrochen haben und dann kam die
Inflationsraten von 40 50 80 und sogar
100% hinzu kommt das Fehlen jeglicher
Reserven und eine re die das komplette
Land
überzog Argentinien begann eine
Veränderung zu wollen und es gab
plötzlich mehr Möglichkeiten es gab
keinen Grund mehr sich auf den
Gradualismus zu beschränken viele
Menschen hatten die Nase einfach voll
und wollten einen festen klaren und
entschlossenen Führer und das war der
beste Nährboden für mil ist libertäres
[Applaus]
narrativ und genau das ist auch passiert
im Jahr 2022 begann an seiner
Präsidentschaftskandidatur zu arbeiten
und kaum ein Jahr später haben wir das
[Musik]
Ergebnis
[Applaus]
aufutsemin für denandel viel
geschlossener alles dreht sich um mi die
dominante Führungsfigur gegen den
Peronismus und das erklärt warum z.B
Wels Fargo B eine 65przentige Chance gab
Präsident zu werden auch wir gingen von
seinem Sieg aus und haben bereits vor
einem Monat ein Video über ihn auf
visualekonomic veröffentlicht ne wir
genauer auf seine dollarisierungspläne
eingehen ich werde es Euch natürlich
verlinken wohl gemerkt m hat gewonnen
obwohl i viele peinliche Schnitzer wie
z.B zum Thema Organhandel unterlaufen
sind
[Musik]
aber wie gesagt konnte auch das seinem
Siegeszug nichts anhaben er ist nun l
präsidente und daher stellt sich nun die
Frage wie eigentlich seine Pläne
aussehen was ist die Grundlage der
Revolution die umsetzen will um
Argentinien wieder zu einem reichen und
wohlhabenden Land zu
[Musik]
machen nun zunächst einmal verspricht er
eine große stasreform durchzuführen er
hat sich verpflichtet die öffentlichen
Ausgaben sofort um 15% zu senken die
Zahl der Ministerien von 18 auf 8 zu
reduzieren Sozialleistung schrittweise
abzuschaffen den öffentlichen Dienst
durch Konzession zu ersetzen und viele
der Unternehmen die sich noch im
Staatsbesitz befinden zu privatisieren
wir sprechen hier z.B von arolinias
Argentinas oder der Ölgesellschaft IPF
das ist es wasber den kettensägenplan
genannt
haben aber das ist noch nicht alles
gleichzeitig hatversprochen sich eine
groß Reform des Bildungs und
Gesundheitssystems einzusetzen die Idee
des libertären Kandidaten besteht darin
den universellen Zugang zu diesen
Dienstleistungen zu garantieren aber das
derzeitige System in ein
Versicherungssystem im Falle der
Gesundheitsversorgung oder in ein System
mit Gutscheinen im Falle der Bildung zu
ändern auf diese Weise würden die
Argentinier einen Anspruch erhalten den
sie dann gegen die Krankenversicherung
und die Bildungseinrichtung Ihrer Wahl
eintauschen könnten ein solches Modell
würde den Wettbewerb fördern und private
Akteure könnten zu gleichen Bedingungen
konkurrieren im Laufe der Zeit würde der
Erhalt der Bildungsschecks oder der
Übernahme der Kosten für die
Krankenversicherung durch den Staat
Einkommens abhängig begrenzt werden so
könnte nach und nach ein System
geschaffen werden zu dem jeder Zugang
hat das aber mehr Wettbewerb viel
weniger Kosten für die öffentlichen
Kassen und eine effizientere
Funktionsweise
aufweist und melei hat sich schon
millionenfach für den Freihandel
ausgesprochen und genau das will er für
sein Land durchsetzen dass es alle
möglichen Barrieren abbaut und sich
einseitig dem globalen Handel öffnet und
dann ist da natürlich noch das was wir
als seinen starvorschlag bezeichnen
können laut m ist es der ultimative Plan
um dem ewigen Problem der Inflation in
Argentinien ein Ende zu setzen wir
sprechen natürlich über die
dollarisierung des
Landes falls euch dieses heiße Thema
interessiert schaut euch doch bitte das
verlinkte visualconomic Video an es
lohnt sich darüber hinaus verspricht
viele der Vorschriften die
argentinischen Wirtschaftsleben die Luft
abschnüren einfach abzuschaffen wir
sprechen von arbeitsgesetzen
Preisregulierung berufsbeschränkungen
und auch von Steuersenkungen mit anderen
Worten habim will das Produktionssystem
des Landes von Kopf bis Fuß umgestalten
und die Frage die wir uns stellen müssen
lautet natürlich ist das alles wirklich
möglich nun lasst uns das mal genau
unter die Lupe
[Musik]
nehmen regieren mit der
Kettensäge
meine Lieben Zuschauer um alle von melei
versprochenen Reformen durchführen zu
können reicht es nicht aus dass er die
Präsidentschaftswahlen gewonnen hat
sondern er muss auch die Unterstützung
des Parlaments gewinnen das Problem ist
dass die Erneuerung der Kammer an in
Argentinien nur teil und schrittweise
erfolgt bei jeder Wahl werden die Hälfte
der Abgeordneten Kammer und ein Drittel
des Senats neu gewählt das heißt im
Parlament wird melei keine Mehrheit
bekommen sein Lager verfügt über
keinerlei Provinzgouverneure und zudem
fiehlt ihm qualifiziertes Personal um
wichtige Schlüsselpositionen zu besetzen
ja die Summe aus LA libertat avanza und
huntos por el cambo hätte eine sehr
klare Mehrheit aber mele würde
verhandeln müssen und das nicht nur mit
einer einzigen Partei sondern mit einer
Legislative die in Argentinien
normalerweise sehr vielfältig ist selbst
innerhalb der gleichen Plattform wie z.B
juntos por el kambo gibt es
normalerweise viele verschiedene
Strömungen die Frage ist also wird m in
der Lage se mit der Opposition zu
verhandeln und Vereinbarungen zu
treffen nun die Wahrheit ist dass er
Selbstzweifel daran hat dass ein solcher
Prozess zustande kommen könnte vor allem
wenn es um größere Reformen geht
allerdings behauptet er er habe einen
Plan bereit als Kandidat hat neue
libertäre Präsident immer betont dass er
auf Volksabstimmungen zurückgreifen
würde und das nicht nur im Falle der
dolarisierung sondern auch bei vielen
anderen politischen Themen darunter
hochspannungsthemen wie z.B die
Legalisierung der Abtreibung das ist
etwas das nicht nur im politischen
Umfeld gewisse Bedenken hervorruft
sondern es gibt auch ernsthaft Zweifel
an den rechtlichen Rahmenbedingungen für
diese Aktion und hier scheint die
gesetzliche Lage ein Gesetz das ohne die
Zustimmung der Opposition nicht geändert
werden kann ziemlich eindeutig zu sein
das Gesetz das eine verbindliche
Volksbefragung vorsieht muss in einer
Sondersitzung behandelt und mit der
absoluten Mehrheit der anwesenden
Mitglieder in jeder der Kammern
verabschiedet werden das heißt Präsident
m könnte ohne vorherige Zustimmung des
Parlaments nur unverbindliche Referenten
einberufen ja er könnte also ein
Referendum einreichen es gewinnen und
dann Druck auf den Kongress ausüben aber
eins muss klar sein das würde jede Menge
Spannung erzeugen und nicht nur das es
wäre auch kein sonderlich schneller
Prozess
so wie es aussieht weckt melee eine
Menge Erwartungen und eine mögliche
politische Blokade könnte dazu führen
dass er entweder seinen politischen
Schwung verliert oder sich um das Schiff
über Wasser zu halten bei der
Legislative einschleimt und wer weiß wie
das enden würde es würde sich sicherlich
um keine gute Strategie handelt das sind
also die beiden Risiken die bestehen
denn das Problem entsteht und wir haben
es in anderen lateinamerikanischen
Ländern schon oft gesehen wenn ein
Präsident viele Erwartungen weckt und
dann nicht die Unterstützung hat um die
versprochenen Veränderungen auch
wirklich umzusetzen das heißt aber nicht
dass mi seinen Willen nicht durchsetzen
könnte indem er z.B eine große Einigung
mit hundosp alcambio erzielt oder nicht
bindende Volksabstimmungen intelligent
nutzt um sein Einfluss auf die
Gesetzgebung in zwei Jahren zu
vergrößern denn eines ist klar während
seiner Legislaturperiode wird es weitere
Wahlen geben und dabei wird unserer
Meinung nach das Risiko dass er keinen
Erfolg haben könnte und dass dies dann
auch Konsequenzen hat definitiv im
Vordergrund stehen vor allem wenn
Argentinien jetzt ein Präsidenten hat
der nicht viele Kompromisse eingehen
will aber natürlich könnte es noch etwas
oder jemanden geben den wir jetzt noch
nicht auf dem Radar haben z.B jemand der
in letzter Zeit hinter den Kulissen
agiert hat und der in nicht allzu ferner
Zukunft eine Schlüsselrolle in dieser
ganzen Geschichte spielen könnte wir
sprechen hier natürlich über keinen
geringeren als maurio Magrib April
2023 es ist offensichtlich dass wir mit
diesen neuen marktfreundlicheren
rupturistischeren und wütenden Ausdruck
der Frustration die Argentinien seit
Jahren mit sich herumschleppt in eine
zweite Runde gehen werden der Kandidat
von gemeinsam für den Wandel der in
dieser Position ist wird zeigen müssen
dass wir neben den veränderungsabsichten
die melei hat die gleichen haben aber
mit Erfahrung und das sollte das
Gleichgewicht zu unseren Gunsten Kippen
der ehemalige argentinische Präsident
hatte nicht nur schon vor Monaten eine
Vorahnung von der libertären Welle nein
er steht selbst seit langem so nah dass
der libertäre Führer im letzten Jahr
diese Möglichkeit
[Musik]
ansprach natürlich F Wahlen und
Wahlkämpfe normalerweise zu vielen
Brüchen und unbrüchen und in diesem Fall
könnte Mar Schlüssel zu einer
gemeinsamen Reformagenda sein aber wenn
eines klar ist dann ist es dass melei
Argentinien von Grund auf reformieren
will und dass er jetzt zum ersten Mal
eine gute Chance dazu hat die Risiken
und die Chancen liegen auf dem Tisch und
deswegen werden wir euch schon bald ein
weiteres Video über diesen
beeindruckenden Politiker und seine
aufregende Agenda präsentieren außerdem
arbeiten wir auch an einem Video über
die großen Chancen die Südamerika als
Rohstofflieferant und Ersatz Russlands
für Europa öffnen könnte vergesst also
bitte nicht visualpolitik zu abonnieren
um sie sie nicht zu verpassen und bis
dahin sind die Fragen erstmal an euch
gerichtet was ist eure Meinung zu habimi
was haltet ihr von seinem politischen
Plan glaubt ihr dass er ihn als neuer
Präsident Argentiniens wirklich
durchsetzen kann ich hoffe dass euch
dies Video gefallen hat und ihr
vielleicht dabei auch etwas gelernt habt
falls ja gibt uns bitte ein Like Teil
mit euren Freunden und diskutiert es mit
ihnen natürlich freuen wir uns auch
jederzeit über eine Spende von euch mit
uns dieses Projekt weiterzuführen den
Link dazu findet ihr in der Beschreibung
unter dem Video macht's gut und bis
[Musik]
bald